Hello hello hello everyone uh good
morning good day to your different
locations wherever you are welcome to
the graph machine learning research and
industry
uh workshop it is the uh one of the
first batch workshops today at connected
data world so welcome to the first day
of the great event and uh today we're
talking about graphl we're talking today
about uh its resour Arch and industry
applications and we have a wonderful uh
panel uh wonderful collection of
speakers joining from all all over the
world different parts of the world many
different time zones u so let me
introduce uh our speakers first so we
have today
Andrea Andreak who is a PhD student at
sama with the gantang it's the top
research Institute Andre is doing uh
cutting edge graph representation
learning research including
combinatorial optimization uh drug
discovery and drug combinations.
Uh I'm I'm welcoming Tiffany Kalahan
from uh uh
from Colorado
from Mets Colorado. Uh Tiffany Tiffany's
interests include uh computational
phenotypic uh symbolic AI representation
learning proistic modeling and she is
also a overall all things web all the
things of fair transparent science uh
yeah and a supporter of open source
development continue on open source we
very happy to have Charlie Hoy here who
is the main uh contributor to the open
source pike library and also Charlie is
a postoc fellow at Harvard Med School at
the laboratory of systems of
pharmarmacology.
Uh and uh right now he
lives in both Germany and and US. Uh and
uh we have Sergey Vanov who is a
researcher at CTO AI lab in in France in
Paris and uh his interests include
AppML, data science for graphs, graphML,
recommener systems, reinforcement
learning and uh Sergey also a lead
editor, the main editor of several media
channels about GraphML. So he's also one
of the very mo most updated guys uh in
in in the topic regarding research and
industry and uh yeah my name is Michael
Galin. I am a postoc at miler
and uh I'm also doing graph
representation learning geometric deal
and I'll be moderating the session today
and uh yeah let me say a few words about
our format. So we have prepared for you
a few topics which will be very
interesting to discuss. uh we have
collected a nice uh
a nice average uh a nice variety of uh
uh topics of applying graph ML in
industry in academia and we will have
time for questions uh I think last 15 to
20 minutes we'll have questions but
still feel free to put them in chat I
will be reading the chat uh yeah and uh
I think later closing to the end of the
session we will be able to take
questions online but uh yeah feel free
to write them in the chat and addressing
our speakers or general generally the
panel [snorts] and yeah we'll try to
answer them ASAP
all right
it's uh time to start then I have we are
in a in a good shape now yeah so
Today we're talking about GraphML and uh
its different applications and uh the
main topics are
not not particularly some deep questions
of research or uh or some particular
implementation questions but we'd rather
would like to cover breadth and variety
of tasks solvable with with Graphanel in
uh in academia and in industry and the
challenges that we are facing. right now
uh especially those that can be uh like
[snorts] that can be pretty sensitive uh
in real world applications.
So uh yeah let's start first uh with uh
with the data. So as any sort as any
structured semiructured format uh graphs
are built from some from some data and
there are many questions uh or as to
creating creating the graph and uh we
can say that generally it is it's all
about the data. So I would like to start
the discussion with a general question
to our great speakers. So how do you
create and and maintain graphs? What is
your original uh source of of graph
data? And [snorts] uh uh importantly, oh
yeah, let's start with that then will be
a nice uh a nice followup. So uh
Tiffany, would you like to start?
>> Sure, sounds great. So most of the
graphs that I'm involved building are
biomedical in nature. So I tend to use a
combination of linked open data sources
from places like comparative toxico
genomics database uniprot but all of
them I I join them or anchor them to a
central source which tends to be
ontologies mainly because of of the
training and the way that I was brought
up. They offer a nice sort of
epistological background if you will or
framework to build on. So I tend to mix
leveraging open data sources linking
them to ontologies and then enhancing
them with different sources like the
literature and things like that.
>> Right. So in your in your work the
graphs are backed with the with a big
theoretical framework with the
structured models with ontologies.
>> Yes. And uh yeah that's interesting if I
ask Andrea for about the same uh in in
her task
what's what's your with your thoughts do
you have this strong uh background
semantic modeling aspects
>> so I think I I I came across uh graphs
at different levels
>> uh maybe a bit less structured so one
level so I while I worked on the drug
discovery side and drug combinations and
so
uh one like uh yeah
like low level and maybe uh would be
like the graph of molecules. Uh so
that's a very usually very small graphs
we're looking at. Uh and then there's a
graph of these graphs um where we have
interactions between drugs and
interactions between drugs and proteins
and between proteins and protein protein
interactions and so on. So there you can
think of we might have like a a higher
level graph. Um and but more more
recently I've actually been very
interested in building my own graphs in
the context of reinforcement learning
where we have agents uh and I I
generally think that uh like from a
research point of view like what excites
me is agents that build their own graphs
from their experience. Um so if we think
like what what's interesting to me is
that we humans sort of do this like we
create relations between objects in our
head like this chair usually goes with a
table or something like that. So I think
agents should also have a bit of that.
Uh so that's what I've been I've been
doing uh more recently.
>> Well, we we'll jump on that on that on
the connected topic very shortly. Uh
there is a super important question
about that to ask. Uh so I would like to
ask next Charlie. So Charlie, you work
more with the biomedical data too. So uh
are the are your sources also more
structured than unstructured? Um so so I
have a similar experience to Tiffany. Uh
I I care a lot about the the underlying
semantics in biomedical knowledge
graphs. Um one of the problems that we
have is assigning a schema to the graph
to make sure that you can bring
different data sources together because
there's no Uber graph that [snorts]
exists with all interesting
relationships that can solve all
problems you might want to use machine
learning for. So I I've worked a lot
with the biological expression language
as a schema that sits sort of in the
middle between the very um let's say
like esoteric way of modeling knowledge
itself that you can do with RDF for any
schema and then the kinds of models that
people build of biological systems that
are really related to the physical
world. And this is somewhere in the
middle. It allows you to kind of go back
and forth depending on what's
appropriate for your applications.
But I also want to um shoehorn in like
another discussion for data structures
like if you go back maybe to the 70s a
little bit before all of our time I
guess um and and people were really
interested in these kernel methods and
and how graphs could be used in other
kinds of machine learning methods. And
back then people were really interested
in just these like uh regular kinds of
graphs that were just like adjacency
matrices. And and I think now we we
didn't say it explicitly but all of us
are really interested in knowledge
graphs which are these sort of typed
graphs that have relations that can uh
have have labels on them and then you
can actually have multiple relations
between uh the same source and target
node and usually people are thinking of
these graphs as triples. Um, the other
thing that's coming up right now is is
also the idea of heterogeneous networks,
which I think there's a lot of different
names for this, so I'm going to use like
Daniel Himlstein's um, wording for it,
which is calling them nets. And this is
the same thing as a knowledge graph, but
there's a very like deep idea of typing
of the nodes as well. Um, and a lot of
the different methods that we're going
to talk about today, they're kind of
applicable for each one of them. Um,
there was sort of a lot of interest in
these normal kinds of graphs. Uh and
then I think the knowledge graph
embedding world sort of picked up in the
early 2010s and actually right now it's
kind of on the downhill as the graph
neural network um hype trend is is
increasing and now we can see we're
actually turning around again where
graph neural networks are now being used
to solve similar problems on knowledge
graphs themselves and even I've seen
some interesting things especially you
know skimming through the pietor
geometric code as I'm sure a lot of us
do you know what are they coming up with
now they're working on heterogenous
networks as well so so I think that's
something for us to look forward that we
might be swinging back. And you know,
the reason I bring all this stuff up and
and going long-winded on this is because
there's a lot of different kinds of
methods that are applicable for each and
uh I think everyone's going to have a
different perspective on those. So,
we'll get back to that when we talk
about the methods themselves.
>> Yeah, we are definitely going in there
in uh in in a few minutes. Uh yeah and
uh Sergey as the uh
as one of the most updated persons in
among us talking about uh graphs and
their origins
or we will
>> it looks like he's doing some stuff. Do
you want me to bring one of these story
books back to entertain? [laughter]
>> Yeah. Sorry about this. Um yeah. So, so
my experience on this is that um there's
actually very distinct um domains I
would say. uh one coming from like
academic literature and
>> um in this case we we often have already
given graphs and uh we we don't spend
much time actually on thinking about
like where where do the graphs come from
and this is easy to do research um uh
setting I would say so uh this is great
if you want to build the the models if
you want to come up with some new new
approaches and so on Um but in reality
in my case for example I work in a
recommendation setting. So my company uh
it does uh billions of recommendations
and uh there are many different teams
that are working on improving
recommendations all the time. And I
found that it's really really hard to
find uh a good representation of a graph
in in in the real world unless it's kind
of already um uh given to you. So for
example in biology I think uh it's it's
uh common place to see the the graphs
because we can represent the molecules
uh as a graph but if you think about
different applications such as
recommendation uh um the graphs that we
create and the graphs that we see in the
academic literature for recommendation
they're often artificial in my opinion.
So
um we actually real
work really hard to to to find and to
crawl this data so that this additional
topological structure uh it uh brings
any some value to us. So for example, I
think um one of the biggest examples of
recommendation and how the graph can can
be used uh in recommendation setting was
the uh page rank uh back in uh to to the
'90s when the graph is composed of the
of the websites and you can use this
websites to analyze the behavior of the
publishers of the users and so on. So
you can use that that kind of signal uh
from the graph. Um nonetheless I think
that most of the recommendation research
that that uses the graphs it's um quite
simplistic in in the form that you
cannot really use that uh as as a single
tool to actually improve the
recommendations. And so I think that um
this aspect of um how to get the graphs
like where where do you get the data is
is super important for many applications
not just recommendation but many others
and uh there is very little little
discussion happening in general u maybe
outside of these uh conferences
um that that talk about how how do you
get actually the data so this is a big
problem I think that uh in in the future
And I see now more and more works uh
that try to obtain those uh uh those
data or approaches how to get the data
uh um but it's still very uh unexplored
u uh field of study I would say
>> right and picking up on the on this
point uh you something you mentioned and
both mentioned uh about real world rats
uh that's uh that's pretty important So
I would like here to draw a line between
uh graphs that appear in graph structure
in real world and something which we
represent as data as graphs. Some some
data which represented is graphs but
it's hard to uh
to decide where if there is an edge. So
the main question here is where does an
edge come from? If it is this edge given
by certain physical laws or or from our
knowledge of biology where we know that
well there is a connection between say
proteins or targets or it's uh something
which we infer from interaction of our
agents for instance in RL scenario or we
we infer some connection between uh
items that are frequently bought
together that we do not we there is
physically in no big
uh big big link among them. So yeah the
question is how it how do you uh
how do you separate those do you think
it is uh it it has some imprint on the
methods that you apply and applications
like do you think that those artificial
graphs should be treated separately as
as natural graphs
because if if you use uh those
artificial graphs where you create edges
based on node representations you
somehow encode already the
representations of your features in into
those edges. Uh yeah, what do you think
about that?
>> I can start maybe.
>> Yeah, please please go.
>> Yeah. So this is actually I'm finding a
very interesting as a as a question. I
think we're not at least in the there
are some somewhat some methods like
tackling this in the in the more recent
months, but I think we should think
about this a lot more. So I think
there's like the way I see it when we
have a graph given so for example for
molec molecules where we consider bonds
as edges that are uh important for the
task then we should use that because
that's extra data that we have but I
think in a lot of the cases the graph is
actually just like something that's
useful for the for the task in the end
it's not the the task in itself. uh so I
think there we should keep the the
machine learning framework like mindset
of uh the model sometimes can like find
patterns that we we haven't given it um
and those patterns could be edges as
well so I think we we generally should
also take into account that the edges
that we are we put into the model are
not the only edges that are important
for the task for the downstream task uh
so I think we should have some some
combination of keeping the data but also
assuming that there might be other
semantic edges that are important for
the task for example. Yeah, I don't
know. So, uh like we can think of
different heristics on determining
what's an age and what's not. Um and we
shouldn't be the like the heristics we
find might not be the only heristics
that are important for the for the task.
>> Can I jump in?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, so um let's say in like
uh I think it's nice to be working in
the the molecule worlds because you
don't have to really worry for a given
molecule uh if if a bond that represents
an edge is is true or not. But uh in
sort of different kinds of graphs like
let's say the ones that we're working
with in the biomedical domain there
there's a couple different issues that
you have. I think the first one is that
a lot of um graphs come from data that
looks like graphs but isn't really
helpful for your learning problem.
Tiffany's giving a nod because she works
with ontologists a lot and um a lot of
ontologies are stored in a formalism
called owl like the web ontology
language and and this is serialized
within RDF and all of us are familiar
with like the idea of the the triples
and RDF is made of triples. So if you
have some sort of graph machine learning
method and you take your RDF graph that
comes from like whatever and you just
stick it inside, you're going to get
nonsense because then then the machine
learning method will try and learn the
way that you model data and not the
actual thing that you're modeling
itself. Um another like really good
example is is that you've got this RDF
schema where you you type nodes within a
lot of RDF uh data and this isn't picked
up by machine learning algorithms
properly. It doesn't really do what
you're expecting it to. I mentioned
earlier the other formalisms and ways of
thinking about graphs that take that
into account better. But this is one
issue. Um, another issue that I'm
working with is is text mining where uh
we want to model the biology itself and
we do want the the edges within our
networks that we learn on to be like
this protein phosphorates that protein.
So the the nodes are proteins and the
edge is a phosphoration. But it actually
takes a long a lot of work to get there
if you're doing text mining because a
lot of people will talk about the same
sort of phenomena on different levels.
uh and so you you also have to worry
about the way that people use language
and you have to convert that all across
many steps um to to cut these you know
edges and in the end you have this idea
of confidence when you're using text
mining and also combining it with
databases and ontologies and um so
machine learning methods don't typically
take into account confidence in the the
graph itself as a a different sort of
thing than maybe the fact that you can
put properties on edges and you can also
learn on those so I'm working more in
the knowledge graph embedding world than
the the GNN world where where it's
pretty extensible what kind of
properties you can put on nodes and
edges in a GNN assuming that you have a
very consistent kind of nodes and edges
in your network. So knowledge graph
embedding models are working on
knowledge graphs that have all sorts of
different kinds of things inside them
and it's it's also a little bit more
tricky when you're using that because
the different kinds of nodes and edges
will have different kinds of properties.
But anyway, the the idea of a confidence
assessment would be something really
important to start adding to our
methodology, which I mean I have ideas
on this, but I've never really succeeded
in it. I think maybe other people are
working on the same sort of thing. When
when your edges are coming from an
unreliable a potentially unreliable
source,
>> which yeah, uh maybe I'm I'm calling the
scientific literature potentially
unreliable. So, if anybody's ever read
some scientific literature, you're
probably thinking, "Yep, he's right.
Uh and we have the first question in
chat. I will uh read it right away. So
regarding the question of whether graphs
are readily available in the real world,
how would you see the role of general
purpose KGs some something large as DBPD
or Wikata? Could they be a way to enrich
non-reational data with graph structure?
So yeah, as Charlie mentioned here, we
definitely use general purpose graphs
for some uh uh text mining for fact
extraction
for some yeah to ground certain
parts of your text into those common
well-known entities.
But it generally a very good question.
How which prior information do you use
in your in your tasks? So uh yeah Andrea
will you like to comment on that? So
your your setup seems to be pretty
complex that working with RLS you would
want maybe
uh to condition MDP somehow to design
MDP somehow to be such that the state of
actions for instance has something to do
with the real world setups. So do you
use any sort of a that prior graph
information that is shared across uh
agent agent environment
the setup?
>> Yeah, I think that would be a a dream
setup actually. Uh like that idea makes
a lot of sense to me. I think that's
what we we want agents in the end to
have like we we we extracted all the
knowledge. we know that knowledge has
been tested uh in some way or another
has been
cleaned or we know it can be useful. So
I think the agents having access to that
would be very useful. uh but I don't
think the the the methods are there yet
or necess or maybe the yeah I think like
right now most of the agents are still
tested in game environments where the
the knowledge graphs that we are looking
at in the knowledge graph field are not
actually uh that that relevant or maybe
yeah we need to look at some very
specific uh type of information from
there but that does sound like something
we would ideally want to merge together
these two these two fields.
Yeah, you mentioned one one important
point. We we'll come to to that later as
to constructing the representation
constructing the graphs on the fly. And
Tiffany, would you like to comment on
the on the sources on a big source of
like the the big holy grail KG that you
would use in uh in your applications?
What would it be? Because DBP and Wikid
data they are general purpose, but
you're working more in the biomedical
domain. What is uh the KG to to work
with there?
>> Oh, that's a good question. I think
I think there's not just one KG I tend
to rely on. I I found that it's safest
is a tricky word, but when you work with
ontologies, you quickly learn that
assumptions are dangerous even in really
well-ared for maintained things. And so
I tend to pick a combination of
different graphs that I can rely on as
sort of subset experts. So if this is a
source I trust for things about proteins
or when I want to know about gene
expression related activities and
functional proteins, I go to the
geneontology
or I rely a lot on stuff like Charlie
mentioned earlier that it's made in the
community by Daniel Himlstein because he
is as attentive to detail I think as I
like to think I am. So picking if my
graph is going to represent the central
dogma and there isn't one great source
that I can trust to do that I'll pick a
bunch of trusted sources that I can one
compare where they have overlap but two
rely on a sort of that set expert for
that domain.
Let's actually continue from from here.
U we started talking about u
storing graphs and about the way how we
how how we process them. I'd like to ask
you a question about communication
interfaces and it depends on the
communicate on the size of the graphs.
So often in say in molecular graphs you
have the graphs itself are very small
but you have millions of them. On the
other hand, when you work with uh large
knowledge graphs, often times it's just
one big one big graph, but it it's a
enormously large graph like wikid is 100
million nodes and uh with molecules, you
often they are comprised of relatively
small amount of unique atoms like
entities if you in that sense but you
have millions and billions there
possible combinations. So the question
is how do you communicate with with a
graph? So if we look at real world
application most often uh say even alpha
fold they have very uh deep connection
with with the pdb protein database and
they also store for instance this data
in data in some database it's impossible
to store such sizes say in memory so u
how is how as as you work in industrial
applications what is the average scale
of the graphs you work with and uh what
would be the Yeah. What do you find the
most efficient communication media there
retrieving and working with them?
>> Yeah, this is a good question because I
think uh this uh really depends as as
always on on the application that you
want to build and we have various
applications in in our company. Um so we
have both types of problems. We have
problems where we have many uh small
graphs. So for example uh there is a
problem of identifying users. users may
have different devices. Um they go from
different IPs uh they um have different
user agents and so on. So they have
different features and then you have
billions of such devices that you need
to connect uh in a in kind of small
small groups. Let's say each person have
like three to five different devices.
You want to know that this is the same
user so that you can um give him better
recommendations. Um so this is one one
one type of problem. Uh another problem
that we have is more like on
representation learning. So you want to
learn um so for example you want to
learn
um the website embeddings. Uh so we have
you [snorts] know you have Google and
Facebook that show you ads and you want
to learn the representation of Google
and Facebook and many other uh websites
that exist. Uh so in in that case you
have more control over which graphs do
do you work on but usually the scale of
of the graphs is in millions or or
billions. So you have millions or
billions of websites for for which you
want to learn uh embeddings.
Uh but then you have control over for
example which country do you consider.
So if for example you cannot consider
the graph for the whole world you can at
least focus on a on a country on a state
so that the the number of nodes will
will decrease significantly. Um in in in
that case you have um this this kind of
balance between the quality of the graph
that you obtain and uh the scalability
issues that you can uh um have in the
future. Um so me personally I worked
with with both types of scenarios. Um
usually it's the question of the
languages they use the uh distributed
settings if you can afford to to use
distributed learn for your uh for your
problems. Um usually for production
scale applications you also cannot rely
on Python scripts or you know libraries.
So you have to write it in scalar or on
C++ uh so that it scales and uh run
robustly. Um and this is this is maybe
we will discuss it in the future like in
in in this uh talk but uh uh I I think
this is important distinction between uh
the research that we do when we use
PyTor geometric or DJL uh or maybe some
other fancy frameworks and uh and in
production setups where you have to rely
on uh kind of lower level uh programming
languages and it's uh much more
difficult to actually run the job.
>> Perfect. And when it comes to uh
querying,
how do you retrieve those graphs? Is it
just a subgraph extraction with uh some
mathematical mathematical thing or it's
more of a some structured retrieval?
>> So if you talk just about the query, we
we have the the graph already. I mean we
we first need to build a graph right so
we need to know which which links exist
in the graph and that will depend again
on the application. So let's say you
want to build a graph of websites then
you actually need to crawl those
websites you need to go to each page uh
see which links exist there save it to
the to the files u and and and then read
it. in terms of uh reading the the graph
like how do you query which nodes exist
uh which edges exist for every every
node. Uh usually uh well I worked on
scenarios which allowed me to read the
whole graph in the memory. So it was
like million uh million edges uh graph
which was uh good enough and again in in
production settings you have usually big
clusters to to run your jobs. Um I
haven't yet experimented with uh with
subgraph uh type of learning uh but um I
think that that could be done and I know
that that is done in uh other
recommendation companies especially in
in China in uh Huawei in BU in Alibaba
uh th those uh companies actually
develop frameworks to run distributed
learning on on billion uh scale graphs
and in
case for sure you have to extract some
part of the graphs only.
>> Mhm.
Nice. And uh Andrea, how how do how do
you communicate with the graphs in uh in
your tasks? It seems to be less
explicit. The graph seems to be less
explicitly defined. So [snorts]
how do you communicate uh with the with
the graph information?
>> Yeah. So I think
yeah I was trying to think of it. Um I
think in general in research there's so
in the while I was working the uh drug
discovery part I think the the graphs
were very uh decided on as in like it's
nothing yeah it's not like uh like in
industry I guess in a lot of the cases
where the graph is changing and you're
you have to do like on um like online
sampling of how that graph looks now uh
like how the website changed or
something like that like you usually
have like a very specific data set and
you process it once and then you work
with it. Uh the the more recent thing
I've looked at where I was learning my
graph uh there I just I I was dealing
with very small graphs and there I used
a model to build that graph. So it was
all like very small scale. Uh like you
you could do it while training the
model. uh so I think in general from my
experience in research there's a lot
less infrastructure on how to properly
query the graph and so on it's more of a
it's a it's a static thing you do it
once uh maybe if you have to do
subsample you you come up with a
subsampling strategy but it's uh it's
basically as little uh extra yeah extra
infrastructure like databases uh
language and so on uh that we're dealing
Yeah, thanks for mentioning those those
concepts of uh uh infrastructural
infrastructural cost and generally
openness of that. Uh I'd like to
continue on on that and uh I know that
Charlie puts a lot of efforts uh on uh
uh preaching uh openness of graphs and
uh how uh easily they can be accessed
with the APIs or some automatic means
that you won't need to interact with a
lots of uh different buttons on those
websites just to download some some
graph.
Charlie, can you comment on the general
availability or how well the the graphs
are available for for us for being at
research or being industry?
>> Gosh, this is a question that sort of
transcends machine learning and becomes
just an issue if you if you use data
that you don't have on your own servers.
Um, you know, I I think the core thing
that got me interested in this is that
people create static data. And not to
pick on you, Andrea, but I would not
suggest uh creating a static um data
that you work with or or at least not
doing it in in the way such that it
can't be automatically updated. So, so
if you're using molecules, perhaps you
want to pull the latest version of
Kemble, for example, Kembell 29 just
came out a month or two ago. And I'm
[clears throat] sure there's a lot of
researchers who are still using Kebell
28 and even Kembell 27 from two, three
years ago just because they processed it
once and that's the file inside their
home folder on their Windows desktop. Um
so so yeah I guess we have to think a
lot about how to get data from places
and and recently I've been thinking
about all sorts of data that has bizarre
licensing. Um there's a really famous
example of something called the UMLS
which is a the unified medical uh what
does the L stand for anyway? It's it's
the terminology system from the the NIH
in the United States which people use to
ground their their diseases, their
chemicals, all sorts of other biomedical
concepts. um they have an awful license.
You have to sign away your firstborn
child to the American government if you
want to download this. So this is a huge
problem for anyone who wants to build a
knowledge graph. And like Tiffany
mentioned earlier, there's no Uber
biomedical knowledge graph like the the
uh DBPedia or Wiki data that you can
just use that. So you do have to pull
from lots of different places and and
yeah, all of them are being updated on
different schedules. And so thinking
about how things are versions and
automating getting the data from them uh
is super important and that has to be
sort of the underlying part and
sometimes this means that like even if
you're a machine learning person you
have to like think about how do I how do
I programmatically interact with the
website so I can click the you know okay
I agree to this and then type in your
username and password automatically you
know from from your programmatic
interface and uh yeah this is terrible.
So like I would implore all data
providers to like have the dump, you
know, have have it archived on a system
like Zenoto where each version of it
gets a DOI and can be downloaded in
bulk. In fact, I'm even telling people
that APIs are bad because a lot of
people say, "Hey, our data is very big.
Maybe we've got a a database that has
billions of relationships or billions of
rows in our database." Um, and and so we
don't want people to have to download
that necessarily. So we give you an API
so you can look for one record at a
time. This is uh this is good for end
users actually. People typically want to
interact with just one or two things at
a time. It's not good for machine
learners. It's not good for people who
are building uh new resources because
you need the whole database and you
can't hit somebody's API a billion
times. I think you can get to probably
10,000 before they rate limit you or
blacklist your IP. And I'm sure we've
all been there.
>> Yeah, we think I answered your original
question, right? That was a super
tangent. [laughter]
>> Yeah, that is a that's pretty much it.
Yeah,
>> Tiffany's got something to add to that,
I'm sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I would like to
actually jump to to Tiffany on that.
>> I was going to say not to not to plug
software testing, although I do plug it
whenever I get the opportunity. Being
someone who who relies who builds a
graph off of several sets of different
sources, I think the thing I've learned
related to this, which Charlie made me
think about, is not only it's really
important to be able to update things
automatically, but it's also really
important to have systems in place where
you can catch errors. So, as much as we
love open source providers, they like to
make changes and not tell you or make
really big breaking changes. And being
able to have a system that can not only
automatically update itself, but also
let you know when something's about to
go wrong and stop early has been
something that I've learned the hard
way, but enjoyed learning because it's a
it's a valuable lesson that helps me as
a data provider be better at it, too.
>> So, quick question about that. So, like
one example that's a huge problem is we
download like drug bank quite a bit and
every once in a while they change like
the name of one of their tags in their
XML dump. So, the only way I've ever
been able to think of that is like have
have something that runs every week and
when it's unable to run like email me
and say, "Hey, you got to go update your
code because the data's changed." Is
that can can you do better than that?
>> No, not yet. I'm a currently leveraging
tons of GitHub actions for those kinds
of things because they're so easy to
configure and pretty reliable and and
easy to decide how do I how much do I
care about this kind of change? How much
do I care about that kind of a change?
So, no, I don't have a I wouldn't say I
have a better system. Probably a more
complicated system, which is not good.
But at least I'm trying to have
something in place so I don't end up
building a knowledge graph and releasing
it and someone going, "What happened to
like nine million edges you had last
month? Where did those go?"
Uh,
>> oh,
I want to to briefly uh I I like what
you and Charlie said. Um
I I think it it emphasized a bit of a
difference between somebody like from my
experience I usually think about the
models and how the models compared on
the same data. Um and that's our that's
the way we've come up with like we we
decide on some data and then we tried
our our different improvements to to the
architectures and see do these
improvements we're making are actually
do they benefit us in any way. But I
think that's uh what they were saying
with actually improving our data get
using what what's most recent is uh is
very important and maybe it's a bit of a
of a gap between the domain and the
machine learning researchers who are
making the models. Um so I think there
should be like a a bit of both like we
should improve our models and one easy
way to see are we are actually improving
is testing on the same data but there
should also be better communication with
the data uh with the the actual domain
we're we're looking at and getting those
most recent updates and uh occasionally
do like changing
uh hopefully before we actually get
overfitting on those datas we of those
data sets we decided on. So yeah, very
interesting point you you made there.
>> I I generally think that the dynamic
nature of of graphs especially those
that change uh very fast and and they're
getting updated that's a some uh
unbridgeidge gap right now in both
academia and industry. So in in academia
we are we we are used to experimenting
with data sets as let's say 10 years old
or five years old. They do not change
over time and uh they are they serve as
benchmarks that we can compare
performance of some algorithms but the
thing is that the tasks change over time
and usually uh those academic data sets
static data sets simply uh cannot catch
up with the complexity of modern of
modern tasks. Uh so Sergey for instance
in uh in industry it it must be very
very visible for you that uh uh users
communicate every day with with
products. Graphs get updated and uh uh
the whole the whole structure might
change. Millions of edges can change
over time. Uh how complex is uh this
tackling of of dynamic nature of
threats? Because every time you think,
oh, I'll probably need to retrain my
whole system based on this new graph I
received yesterday and uh yeah, every or
every some short period of time and then
spend a lot of computational resources
just on that retraining. Can we do
better?
Um so for sure you need to update the
graph like uh you need to constantly
refresh it uh as as uh frequently as
possible uh desiraably
uh but um at least like once a day or at
least uh so often as you can afford
yourself. Um and this is actually the
biggest uh one of the biggest uh
challenges if you want to launch uh some
graph model uh in production to have uh
a deployment of this model uh to be
regularly trained uh so at least like
once a day and also your graph should be
regularly updated at least once a day.
Um we have experimented with models that
don't update the the graphs and as you
can imagine the performance uh drops.
It's slowly starting to to decrease
because indeed users interact with
different products uh links uh between
publishers uh change over time and so
on. So uh there is a loss of information
uh to to the current time um if you
don't update the model and uh in in
general that's as I said this is a major
step if if you want to deploy something
uh you you always need to ask yourself
how you going to to schedule this uh
this thing that you built uh usually any
ML task that that you build in the
industry is composed of at least two
steps it's uh the data set generation
step and uh the second step is training
the model. I think the data set
generation as I said before and many of
you said that it's um somewhat um
invisible to to their academic research
because the data sets are given to you
but in in reality you have to update it
you have to obtain it uh somehow and um
without the work of engineers there's a
lot of engineer work for example how do
you query the the websites so that they
don't don't block you Right. So, uh
sometimes it's even you have to have
some business commercial relationship
with this uh publishers or with the
providers of the data so that you can
you can get it. Um so I think um it it
is important both to to update the graph
and to to have the graph available to
you um in the correct format. Um it is
it is difficult and um it's it's one of
the challenges that that um all all kind
of industry practitioners face.
I hope you you heard me
>> right. Right. Yes. uh and uh from that
let's uh uh talk about the the tasks we
uh we can solve with uh with a gra with
graphs and uh what is the like bleeding
edge of progress there uh
on both sides and in industrial and
Okay.
>> I don't know if everybody can hear
Michael. I can't hear Michael anymore.
>> I can't hear him either.
No,
maybe I can ask Serj a question while
Michael is trying to fix his sound. Is
that okay? [clears throat]
>> Go ahead. Yeah. Yeah, go ahead.
>> So, you mentioned something I thought
was super interesting when you talk
about wanting to be frequently updating
graphs and models. And I'm curious, one
thing that happens a lot in biology is
we'll find that as things get added over
time, things also disappear because we
find something was incorrect or a fact
has changed. And I'm just curious, do
you have specific ways you account for
those kinds of changes in the graphs
that you're using? Or is that something
that happens so infrequently you're not
super worried about it?
Do do you mean the updates to the graphs
themselves or do you mean to the updates
to some information side information for
example to the node features?
>> I think actually either so the the
graphs themselves but also I think I'm
most interested in the node feature. So
how do you know when when a change is
important and when it's happened and and
when does that propagate even up through
the models that you're you're finding
because you can easily I know you can
find them in the modeling side but you
can also find them in the if you have
quality checks or checks to the the
structures you're building too
>> right so in our case uh we resolve it by
just uh fully running the model and
retra fully running the model uh
rebuilding the graph data sets and
getting results in you and then
comparing them to what have we we would
obtain if we would use the the graph in
the past.
>> And
in the end there there's no better check
for you uh that the performance of of
your model uh doesn't degrade is than
the AB test that that you run. So um the
the only thing that you can eventually
do and you should do is to AB test
whether the graphs that you update give
you better performance or not. And this
is what we do constantly. We run AB
tests. Um this is a major step as well
like how to actually scale your model,
schedule your model and so on uh to to
bring it to AB test. Um I think there's
still a lot of work uh in research that
that could facilitate this. uh but
overall
the information on the nodes the
information of the graph uh that changes
constantly. So we cannot really afford
uh you know tracking it and uh trying to
estimate the confidence of our model so
on. So we we we just really run it from
scratch and uh uh hope that it will be
working better than than uh in the in
the past.
>> Thank you. Sorry for sidetracking. Hope
that's okay. [laughter]
>> Yeah, I see a question in uh in chat. So
since uh repro reproducibility is a
major aspect of research, how do you
think academia can address uh the gap in
uh research on dynamic and evolving
reps? So Charlie, would you would like
to comment on that?
>> Sure. Um the first is I I want to
mention that this is like a very
unrepresentative panel of the machine
learning world as far as I can tell
because a lot of us seem to really enjoy
reproducibility and like reusability and
uh from from my experience working with
machine learning most most of research
is not either of these things um and and
so I want to plug I think I think the
idea of online learning u maybe if
you're not familiar with that this is
one of the ideas that we're all getting
at is can we update our models as the
graph updates and this I think is like
one of the holy grails of of both uh
adtech and also biio medicine um I
mentioned earlier we're doing text
mining every day there's there's some
number of thousands tens of thousands of
papers published every day so there's
new knowledge that's uh created on on a
normal basis and so we can also think of
this in the bio medicine um so so online
learning would be good I think a first
step towards that is something called
inductive learning and I really Want to
give a shout out to to one of my
co-workers and collaborators in the Pyen
project, Medie Ali and and Max Baronorf
who really worked on this in addition to
Michael himself who who also contributed
to one of these recent uh papers they
were working on in inductive link
prediction which allows you to kind of
go out of the the knowledge graph and
the set of entities and relations that
you've given the model and say hey can
you tell me something about an entity
you've never seen before and in a
realistic scenario this is like okay
we've got new data coming into the graph
it it doesn't match any of the entities
or relations that were there, but we
still need to be able to do something to
solve our problem. And there's all sorts
of different problems. So, I think this
inductive link prediction is it's a very
new and hot topic. I don't personally
know so much about it. I can only uh
point you in the direction of some of
the giants. Um, but as people become
more comfortable with this, I think the
holy grail of online learning is going
to become a more realistic thing that we
can do. I think the industry will adopt
it first because their their graphs by
all sorts of different reasons are more
dynamical in nature but also we'll start
doing this in settings in biio medicine
and you know to to some extent in
chemistry and chemiratics as well.
>> Um so yeah reproducibility in general
though is still an issue. this requires
people to start thinking about another
topic which I I won't go into more than
just now is that it's it's not enough to
be a a machine learner these days. I
think everybody needs to consider
themselves a software engineer to a
certain extent and I know that's that's
difficult and I know it's a skill that's
not taught in school and it's a skill
that's not valued in academia. um you
know, we're working for professors as as
grad students at some point who who have
never written a line of code in their
their life, so they probably don't care
about software engineering. Uh you know,
they're thinking, "Oh my god, they're
doing machine learning and I'm their
mentor. What are what am I doing right
now with my life either?" Um so, so
yeah, this is something that people need
to I guess be motivated. I think it's
kind of up to us to start pushing this
sort of thing to people we work with.
I'm I'm pretty sure that like I've done
this too, Michael, like given you some
some tips on software engineering
practice just because of the pyene
things. Uh yeah, so so I think everybody
here should probably think about that a
little bit more and um it starts with
the code being able to be rerun and then
we can think about the science that's
built on top of that and then last step
is you know the applications to the real
world to the industry.
>> Yeah, that's very very relevant. Uh I
Andre wants to add something.
>> Yeah, Charlie made a lot of great
points. I don't know which I I I'll
start from the from the end like uh you
said like about inductive learning and I
think that in graph neural networks
that's a I think a default nowadays. Um
but it it made me think of an even like
more general general problem of
generalization.
uh so when our data is changing and
usually we we have models that are
trained on some specific distributions
and while those distributions are
shifting our models don't work anymore
and I think along with reproducibility
we should also think more about
generalization and out of distribution
generalization where is happening like
uh in things are evolving we we the data
in a year won't look the same as data
now uh so I think that's a a bigger
question. Um, yeah, I I had some other
point but I forgot what I was. Oh maybe
yeah the gap so so the other the other
part of the the question the gap in
research on well there is some some work
on like dynamic uh graphs so like
temporarily dynamic graphs uh so I think
there's been some some papers uh
recently on this and uh yeah I think
that uh that's emerging slowly so so I
think but the the thing I I would bet
most on uh is more communication between
research and the the the area the domain
to which the the models will be applied
because I think researchers have
slightly different incentives than the
people who are actively actively working
on the on some data and are just
interested in that task. Uh I think for
researchers we are like we're looking at
some specific metric and we're we're
interested in seeing those metrics go
up. Um and I think once we we get our
models to be better, we should also talk
with the like not stop there but use our
like pass on our knowledge from what
they've seen uh to the people who are
more actively working with the data. So
I think yeah communication and more
interdisciplinary
uh work would be would be my my solution
for this.
you you you mentioned very important
content that's exactly what I would like
to to talk right now. This is generally
a gap between industrial tasks and
academic tasks. Uh often in uh in the
industry we have a certain business task
we have business metrics we have uh yeah
task x I want uh uh to solve task x and
uh often it does not directly
correspond to a certain ML task. So uh
then it you need some uh yeah a team of
engineers to think how to frame this
business task into a ML task being that
a regression task or classification or
link prediction. Uh so uh
yeah I'd like to start with Sergey. So
uh uh c can you tell us how do you
uh
oh can you hear me now?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So can can you tell us uh how do
you start uh with the bridging the gap?
So when you have a certain business
task, certain metric you want to
optimize, how uh what steps do you take
to
frame it as a machine learning problem?
>> Okay. So it is actually easy uh because
I work in AI lab. So there's no question
for me to use other tools than than ML.
Uh so I have to come up with ML uh
approaches uh to solve some business
test. Um there are other engineers who
work on nonML tasks uh nonML approaches
and uh they often as as you can expect
they often work uh better than uh more
sophisticated approaches.
Um and then the question is uh how how
do you decide that you you want to apply
some graph approach instead of some
non-graph approach because I think um
GNS in general now getting more traction
people talk about it like big companies
start using them but I I think in
popularity they still are not as um
popular as transformers or as RN and um
and all those uh buzzword models. So I
think that um to convince people
actually to use genans or to to use some
other graphing representation models not
necessarily genens
uh you have to be quite convincing. You
have to actually explain people that
there is some value in in the topology.
There is some signal coming from how
users interact with products. uh and you
cannot capture this signal from other
approaches. So the ultimate test for you
will be still the AB test. Uh but to to
convince people that you you have to
work on this and usually you you work
with somebody. Um yeah, you have to to
find some some good um uh convincing
case and uh uh for example in my case um
I can say I I know that page rank was uh
was a good uh algorithm back back in the
days and uh I know that using um a graph
between publishers between websites is
something that people easily understand.
So this is uh quite convincing to people
to understand why do we need to use the
the graph structure. In other in other
cases it's it's not as obvious. So
sometimes you you can say that uh you
can um represent a problem as metric
factorization problem between users and
products and vectorize the the users and
and and products um and it will be
enough um and it actually works uh in
the industry not just in our company but
in many others. So
I I think the answer to to your question
is um for for AI right now there is no
problem for like every everybody is is
convinced that we need to use AI to to
solve business problems um on on many
different levels um but in terms of the
graph approaches it's not as easy and uh
you need to have a good convincing
skills to to actually prove that uh the
graph topology uh makes sense and I
think that uh in some domains it's
easier for example in biology in
material design it could be easier to
convince people that graph approaches
are easier to use and better to use.
So so I've got a slide that explains
some of the stuff in biio medicine and
so I'm going to put it as a challenge.
I'm going to put the slide up and I'm
going to let Tiffany and Andrea explain
it. They've never seen this slide
before. So, but we also, you know, said
we're going to try and use some of these
cool features in the live webinar. So,
I'm going to screen share for a second.
Um, and let's let's see how that kind of
works out. I don't know. We we'll live
on the edge and I'll share my entire
screen and you guys can look at this
slide. So, can we all see the slide? All
right.
>> Yes.
>> So, so the idea is is that biomedical
knowledge graphs that that are really
representing the mechanisms of biology
and the interactions between biomedical
things. I think the the link prediction
task is is pushing us towards solving
these real world problems. And I'll
leave it at that. So I I now challenge,
you know, Tiffany and Andrea to explain
my slide they've never seen before.
>> You want to go first, Andrea?
>> I can I can tackle the first uh point
because that's the one I'm most familiar
with. Um so link Oh, okay. So we're
looking at a very specific question
here. So in um
I think that the graph we're talking
about is a graph of drugs and proteins
uh with like a heterogeneous graphs with
drug drug connections drug protein
connections protein protein connections
something I I mentioned at the beginning
uh and sometimes so the the relation is
a drug protein is that that drug is is
useful for for for that protein target.
uh drug drug connection could mean these
two drugs are similar or maybe these two
drugs uh will will interfere with each
other. They could have side effects. Um
a protein protein connection is yeah if
there depending on which where it was
extracted extracted there's there's some
similarity in the protein. uh but a
graph like this is useful because uh one
reason why it's useful is because uh we
can find new edges between drug and
proteins which will tell us that drug
will be useful for for that protein
target. Uh so that's a way of uh if if
we find this new age this this could
mean that we found a way to take the
drug for from its initial uh use and
have find a new use for it. So I think
uh Viagra was a very popular case. It
was initially designed for some heart
disease. Uh not I might have not used
the proper medical term but it was
designed for for yeah something very
heart specific and you know you know
what it's used for now is so um yeah I
think that's repositioning uh drug
discovery.
Um yeah, there's a lot I actually have a
a slide going in detail in drug
discovery, but I can I can leave that
for later. Uh so yeah, if if you want to
to follow on any of those other points,
I think that's the one I'm most familiar
with. Perfect. And I think you set it up
great and are making my job much easier
uh in the sense that I think what this
slide does a really good job of
highlighting is that in biomedical
knowledge graphs given their
heterogeneous nature you can use link
prediction tasks to solve a bunch of
different kinds of problems. And what I
think is implicitly implied by this task
is that if you if you build your graph
correctly and correctly in the sense not
just of of accurate connections between
entities but if you're representing
mechanisms of of biology then you
actually stand a good chance to borrow
from similar types of tasks because the
biology underlying what you're studying
should lend well to those things. So for
example, by looking at drug discovery
and repositioning tasks, you can also
say something about target
prioritization with respect to different
proteins that are involved in different
diseases. So I like I don't know exactly
what Charlie was hoping we'd highlight,
but I like how Andrea set it up that
that with these link prediction tasks on
biomedical knowledge graphs, the goal is
ultimately to predict new relationships
that don't exist. But what's highlighted
really well here is that in the process
of doing that, you can also learn other
types of relevant biological entities
that might not directly be the edge
you're trying to predict. So it might
not be a new chemical disease edge, but
you might make new additional edges in
the graph which could eventually lend to
discovering new chemical disease edges.
>> Yeah, that's great. So can I add one
thing to that?
>> Yeah. Um to so for everybody who's not
super familiar with the way that drug
discovery works, I'm sure you've all
taken a pill at some point or a shot and
people need to understand the biology
and then they need to create a molecule
that that should be active that
eventually a person somewhere in the
world is going to take. And I think the
the point of this slide is also to show
that all of these tasks are things that
a a real scientist would be doing in the
lab typically based on their intuition
which is is based on a very small amount
of knowledge they have. And and where we
stands to really do a lot of good is to
use AI on on knowledge graphs to propose
what experiments should be done next.
Can we help the scientist who goes into
the lab that puts a a chemical that's
been synthesized into a test tube with a
protein and then they decide how how
well that works in the real world? Can
we make them pick the right chemical,
you know, five times out of 10 instead
of one time out of a 100? If we do that,
we can we can speed up the very long
process of drug discovery. And you know,
these have very real impacts, right? So,
so when a chemical is is chosen to work
for a disease, there's a lot of people
that will be helped potentially for the
industry, there's a lot of money to be
made sort of on every side, it wins. So,
all of these tasks correspond to things
that people will go into the lab or into
the clinic and test and um yeah, so so
it's it's very like there's a very
onetoone correspondence between thinking
about predicting new links and knowledge
graphs and the tasks that actually are
meaningful within the industry and you
know the humanitarian side as well.
So, I'm going to stop sharing the
screen. Anybody wants that slide, I'd be
happy to share it. Um
>> I don't I don't want to make this uh
very like very drug discovery specific
but I actually have a a nice uh task
that follows on on child is uh so
there's there's this one task that I
find very interesting just from because
I think it it really shows the the where
graph machine learning could be useful.
Uh can you see my screen?
>> Yep. Yes.
>> Okay. So this is the the slide I was
talking about. But the task I'm
interested in actually and the task I
let me just uh so there's this polyfarm
pharmacy task which I find uh
particularly
um
particularly interesting as a as a as an
example of where graph machine learning
can be useful because uh poly pharmacy
is like when you take multiple drugs and
you have some side effects because you
took those multiple drugs and the thing
is this is not something we can people
can can test in the lab like when making
a drug they can't test all possible drug
combinations and they can't say yes you
can't take this one drug with this other
drug because that's that will be a very
large space to test and uh they don't
have the resources and they can't really
make people take all possible drug
combination so I think this is somewhere
where machine learning can be useful
because yeah so here I like this
animation because polyarm pharmacy is
like you take two drugs they're supposed
to be the good guys and then in the
process of saving the world they end up
doing some more damage than they than
like other than the things they're
solving. Uh so yeah, I think this like
polyfarm pharmacy for like graph machine
learning for polyarm pharmacy is one
example I really like for for why this
is useful. Uh yeah, that was my my short
tangent.
>> Yeah, thank thanks for bringing up this
uh important concept. That's indeed uh
exactly the the the next topic of of the
discussion.
So we started talking about
different say adver ad adversarial
effects of the models when we apply them
in real world setups.
uh it has to do a lot with uh
uh this notion of of how much we believe
uh the models how much we can rely on
them how fair they are and uh yeah let's
talk about ethics a bit uh and uh for
that uh yeah I'd like to ask Tiffany to
comment on uh
so do we know right now
uh what can uh who and who will be who
could be the bad guys or how the good
intentional models can suddenly turn to
bad behaving models that we suddenly do
not want to use them anymore. There is a
very I think in research uh like
hardcore research it's still less
understood problem that will just
continue to push the benchmarks further
and further at some point it can be like
a double-edged sword. So do what do do
you have a
estimate like when or what factors
contribute to the to the fact that some
models suddenly become uh bad models?
>> So I will I'll preface by saying I come
to the pres what I bring to this
question is a background that's firmly
rooted in thinking about what data
you're learning on first. And so I think
the the thing that's really challenging
and I'll I'll try to answer this in a
broad way and then come back
specifically to your question. I think
what's really hard in the biomedical
domain in this aside from the things
we've already talked about in in this
panel is that a lot of the data sources
you might want to be used could be
really difficult to find and could
require manual annotation. And to get
around that, you might use a less
trusted source because it will help you
train a model now, get to an endpoint
sooner. And I think some of the danger
is really what can you trust, but how do
you know what you can trust if you're
not implicitly examining every source
robustly and rigorously? How do you know
you can trust it? And that's a slippery
slope because I think you you can
quickly go from some highlevel
examination of a data source to make
sure it's it fits the use case that
you're trying to solve to really
spending 99% of your time fixing other
data that you weren't intending to do.
So I think what happens a lot and can be
dangerous and I think we saw a lot of
this in early drug repurposing work
around COVID is that it's tempting to
use these models. you trust on data that
you think is good and get answers that
seem high confidence for the metrics you
trust but without including the right
domain experts like and Andrea mentioned
earlier early in the process and
checking in with them frequently you
could be tempted to suggest oh look at
these great drug candidates that we have
these would be perfect the model looks
great we've done all this rigorous
testing of the data these look great but
taking a step back I think the danger is
how much can you trust a source And how
do you really validate things beyond the
existing data we have? And so I think
I'm speaking very generally to say I
think it's really difficult in biio
medicine. I think it's easy to see how
big robust models are useful and no
doubt that they can make a huge
difference in patient lives. But the
harder question is when is a model good
enough? When is a prediction confident
enough to to trust? So I don't know if I
answered that specifically but more
talking broadly about the the dangers
and challenges of the data and the model
especially models that are built on
questionable data.
>> I remember that case. Oh
>> no, you go ahead and then then
>> yeah
just one small insertion. The fact that
sometime in US the there was some hype
about applying a like horse uh med
medicine for
>> treating COVID and uh it was smashed by
all the
all the science people but for some
reason it was it was still continuing to
be spreading like yeah we should use
this.
Yeah, the horse dewormer as a way to to
get rid of COVID was terrifying
for many reasons. But I think and
Charlie, let me say one last thing and
I'm going to leave it to you. I think
the the the slippery slope of biology is
that one of the great and challenging
things with interpreting results is if
you have a really good biologist who is
has a good breadth of systems biology
knowledge, they can really easily come
up with an explanation for any set of
new edges you provide them. And the
question is how hard was it to come up
with that? How much were you twisting
things to make it fit to justify a a
result that you just came up with? or is
it actually true? So, I think that's the
other thing that's challenging is
biology is is really complex and you can
twist it in meaningful ways and
dangerous ways.
>> Okay, I'm done.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, I I added this onto our
little chart like what were all the evil
things people did with GraphML in the
last couple years? And I think I wrote
COVID question mark question mark
question mark because because it was
really a total fiasco. We saw some of
the the most prominent graph machine
learning researchers and I'm not going
to name any names here but if you look
at back at some of the papers you'll see
exactly what I'm talking about who who
completely threw away the concept of of
t training testing and and validation.
They said data leakage doesn't matter
and basically I I'll present like the
results they presented. They said we
took all the databases about you know
whatever we trained some stuff you know
some simple models that weren't
appropriate from from the knowledge
graph embeddings we we predicted uh some
things and look in our our predictions
we got uh like some things that are
already in the clinic and and I can't
unpack all the things that are wrong
with the way that they did this but the
the short version is they they didn't
consider the biases that are implicit in
using knowledge to to make new
predictions
and that you can't you can't say that
you win and you've been successful by
making a prediction about something
that's already known. And and in biio
medicine, the the problem people have
when they use machine learning is they
they come up with some metrics, they
validate on stuff that's already known,
they say our method is able to reproduce
what we already know and then they call
it quits. And this is the danger of of
machine learning moving into biology,
which we have a lot of growing pains in
the last 10, 15, 20 years. um you know
it's it's a little different in in the
research field because the followup in
the way that it should be communicated
when you do machine learning in the
biomedical domain is you say we able to
make these predictions
we can prioritize things and now we have
to do the hard work of convincing
somebody why they should go to the lab
or the clinic test it and there's no
success there's no there's no mean rank
there's no hits at whatever the the
success is measured by did you create
something that's of of value to the
society or or to the that you're in,
assuming it's going to make some money.
Uh, and that's, you know, something you
have to go to the lab and test. So,
machine learning is not the end. And so,
we have a mindset problem that like
we're here, we built a great model, we
trained it, we're cutting edge, we
presented it at Nurips, and like that's
it, move on with our careers. But like
that's not the purpose of machine
learning. It's it's a tool to solve
problems. And I'm not trying to put down
people who are are currently working in
the graduate studies that are coming up
with the coolest, newest models that
help us to solve these problems. You
have to imagine there's like it's got to
be a purpose. And then once you have
that purpose, you need to be guided by,
you know, what problem am I really going
to solve? And the the last part of that
is we're not helping as a community by
fixating on metrics within ICLR within
NERIPS. You know, when when you don't
have a model that has a billion more
parameters than the last model, and you
don't defeat the state-of-the-art by at
least 2%, you may just get rejected. And
uh after that happens two times in your
first two years of your graduate
studies, you realize, okay, I was trying
to do science and and now what I need to
do is is beat the system so I can
graduate. And [clears throat] so, okay,
I just I just dumped a bunch of things
that we're all worried about at the same
time right now. But we have this issue
and I don't know how to fix it. I think
with the the first part, you know, the
COVID crisis, it's so a matter of
solving the problem of communication and
uh making sure that what what Tiffany
said is that you need to have like
domain experts reviewing the outputs of
machine learning models because they're
the only people who are going to be able
to action from it. Um how how to deal
with the issue that machine learning has
all sorts of messed up incentives. I I
can't do anything about that. Um but we
can we can be aware of that and I know
everybody's forced to review for these
conferences when they submit to them. So
the best you can do is keep that in mind
while you're reviewing is that you
should be rewarding people who are who
are making contributions and not ones
who are just trying to game the system
and and beat the metrics.
>> I think that's so important. I just have
to say I totally agree with what you
said especially from a clinical
perspective. You can have a great model
but if you walk up to a clinician and
say hey look we've got this really great
thing. It works really well on all this
data. they're going to go, "No,
I'm not using that. Why should I trust
that? Give me the simpler one." So,
thanks for for bringing that up,
Charlie.
>> And uh I'd like to continue on that uh
on the fact that yeah, do we need those
complex models and real taxes tasks?
Sergey, can you can you tell us what
would be the uh your working horse in
your everyday applications? Is it some
state-of-the-art model from recent
Europe or I clear or is it or it is it a
vanilla PPR or page rank from uh 20
years ago which can buy alcohol now by
by its age?
>> Yeah. So this is a great question
because I I'm kind of known uh in in
among my friends
being a type of guy who is critical to
to the current research and amount that
we do. uh because I think uh in reality
it's very hard to beat very simple
heristics and I often kind of tweet or
retweet uh similar thoughts. So in our
case uh and in recommendation in general
I think the
um status quo of the model that that we
should use is the following. We we first
have uh usually we operate in the large
space of of candidates. So imagine you
uh do drug discovery. You have large
space of uh molecules that you can
output as a candidate or we want to do
recommendation to the users. We operate
in the billing scales of of different
products that uh different companies
have. Uh so we first need to narrow down
the search to let's say hundreds of
candidates and then uh what we do is we
uh for this 100 candidates we have more
complex model that tries to get more
features and uh do more accurate uh
decisions. So um for the first phase
when you try to narrow down the search
you usually uh can do whatever model you
want as long as it uh brings some uplift
in a test. So for example, you can use
GNN uh as a way to bring some uh 10 more
candidates to the final pool of of of
the candidates or you can use uh deep
learning models and so on.
Um at the second phase however because
you often need to do it well for online
companies like YouTube, Instagram, uh
Facebook, you need often to do very
quick decisions for many users at the
same time. So it could be like you you
have to do billions of recommendations
per second. Uh you have to be very quick
and therefore the models that you use
cannot be like a transformer model that
has you know millions of parameters. So
different companies have different uh
models for this but usually it's a
classical machine learning models like
logistic regressions uh that uses a
bunch of features though. So it tries to
replace those uh
multilayer parameter settings with uh
many input features coming from the
products coming from the user behaviors
and so on. Uh but it's still very very
simple models usually like one two layer
MLPS uh that that work pretty well. Um
so yeah it's uh it's it's kind of a mix
between uh deep learn that uh people now
highlight uh in in research but in the
end it's uh it's more classical model.
So it could be even like a heristic that
uh picks uh the the final recommendation
the final candidates out of the final
pool of of of uh uh of candidates. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I remember that you had a paper
last year uh at a big venue uh infusing
or comparing those classical decision
trees with uh with some genets and it
showed the results that are very close
to to state-of-the-art maybe the
state-of-the-art results and was uh yeah
still using those uh
pretty well well-known techniques from
from the literature that are 15 20 years
old.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So exactly. So this is
the paper that clear this year. So it
was like clear 2021 about the fusion
between uh gradient boosted decision
trees uh which like people using XG
boost and cat boost like GBM and more
classical more recent GNS like how do
you combine them together so that they
work well on grass with um large feature
space. Let's say you have a note with uh
his social network where each person has
an age um he has some university that he
graded from he has uh I don't know
income and gender and so on. So these uh
features uh come from different uh
scales uh they have different nature and
uh classical JNS if you apply them on on
this type of uh graphs they don't
usually work well because uh those have
an assumption on on the node features
that they are kind of uniform uh scaled
and also have the same uh meaning. So it
could be for example embedding that
represent the node features uh and and
therefore yeah like how do you try to
use some existing tools such as GBDT
which is known for 20 years uh on on
this type of problems. Um and yeah that
that reminds me actually how uh we do
recommendations as well because uh this
uh tools that we use this models that we
create uh they u come in from different
domain. So it could be for example that
we have metric factorization tool that
gives you a list of of recommendation
but it could be also uh GNN or it could
be some heristic that just a SQL query
you know and and then you aggregate this
all all candidates together and you have
a meta model that operates on on on top
of that. So uh I I think this is the
approach that actually many companies
adopted. I know that uh YouTube does
recommendations like this uh Netflix
does recommendation like this and so on.
So uh and it's the fact of the the tool
it's it's somewhat uh like ensemble
model uh though it's it's it's not
exactly trained end to end but it's uh
it's trying to aggregate many different
models uh for the end task.
>> Cool. I'd like to continue on that and
uh talk a bit uh we have some time about
uh uh research prospects and uh cool
research tasks that are getting enabled
by graphl research and uh yeah I'd like
to start with Andre about that. So
you're working on a very like top-notch
of graph representation learning on in
the mix of combinatorial optimization
reinforcement learning. Uh yeah c can
you tell us a bit more uh what's the
pretty much about those new opening
horizons that we can know tackle with
the graph presentation learning. Yeah,
I'm very happy that you you started with
me because I I was actually going to to
continue on Charlie's different and
serious points of uh the downsides of
using graph machine learning in the real
world and I I do generally think that it
machine learning shouldn't replace
anything. It should be a help tool to
humans to to the experts. U but I do
think that for some task it does a great
job and some like playing a bit of the
devil's advocate. I think like also not
using them can be a detriment to like
it's basically a way of not taking the
action we should take. So I think alpha
for is a great example there like we
know that does great great things. We
shouldn't just ignore it because it's
not perfectly interpretable. We should
al we should not also just like assume
this is the the ground rules. Yes,
that's like there should be a way of
like a checking of the of the model's
results and so on. Uh so I think for
some very specific tasks like closed uh
closed uh domain tasks we can have great
machine learning models that can do
things and uh there is there are a lot
of u like uh I think even yeah even
companies like you Uber it uses graph
machine learning uh Twitter I think
probably uses something I know there was
a startup doing graph machine learning
for detecting fake fake news that got
acquired by Twitter so I assume there's
some of that in there too. uh Pinterest
uses uh something like graph sage but uh
like a more developed version. So I
think there's a lot of examples of graph
machine learning being used. Um and I am
quite optimistic about it. I think also
like if we go towards more specialized
software, we'll be able to run more
complex models as Sergeio saying right
now we might not be able to run a
transformer with millions of parameters
but um like same like graph graph neural
networks for example are something that
doesn't play quite well with GPUs but
I'm hoping that in the end we'll have
some more specialized software for
hardware for uh graph uh graph data so
that will also enable some of those
complex models that we know are doing
well but for which we don't have the
hardware resources to to run. So I don't
know if I quite answered there's a lot
of I'm just I want to say that like
coming from the user side and seeing a
bit of what's being currently applied
and uh in which direction are going I
think there is still quite a lot to be
optimistic about uh in the graph machine
learning in the real world. uh a follow
up that direct followup question on that
uh do you think there is still a room
for smaller tailored models or we slowly
going towards uh those huge enormous
models that are being sort of a small
vendor lock soft vendor lock because
only those big companies big tech can
afford to train them so uh before we had
say yeah SVMs on very small data sets
that you can run it on laptop now if you
want you cannot deploy GP3 three because
it resides on closed Microsoft servers.
Yeah. What do you think? Do we have a
GraphML future uh for larger models or
still small models can be there?
>> Yeah, that's a great question. I have a
very particular view which might be uh
like I think the the research world
might be a bit split on this one. Um, so
I generally think intelligence in
general won't emerge from just throwing
a lot of data at a huge model and hoping
it deres the right patterns. I do think
that we should use the knowledge like
the all those huristics we know of and
all those uh inductive biases and so on.
I think we should have those in the
models and not just count on on the
model inferring from a lot of data. So I
am a bit on the side of smaller models
with correct inductive biases and that I
mean that's that's one of the main
reasons why I'm working in this field. I
do think that we shouldn't just uh like
apply an MLP to billions trillions of
data samples and that's it. Uh an MLP
would be able to do all like all the
tasks we need but that that's not what I
what I think we should do. So I I am on
the small models uh side.
Yeah, that's a pretty interesting
question to all our our old speakers.
What guys do you think about that?
Are we get going to get vendor locked or
we still have some uh model independent?
>> I I have like a a tangent to that. I I
think the answer might be yes. Like if
you want to use GPT3, there's no chance
that an academic lab is going to train
something like that.
Well, there is a open there are open
source initiatives by hacking phase for
instance that are they are training 100
billion models 100 billion parameter
models in the federated learning setup.
So it's like unifying thousands of
personal computers personal GPUs to
train those those big models. So trying
to catch up with that democratizing
uh this large scale training
>> and that that's really interesting. I
wasn't aware of that but that's what
exactly the point I was going to go
towards. I think that the future that
would really make GNN's all kinds of
graph machine learning methods and and
every other kind of machine learning
people are interested in is is more of a
focus on methods that are faster and
more efficient. And and I'll give a
shout out to the University of Wisconsin
group that's creating this tool called
Marius, which is a new way of training
uh knowledge graph embedding and GNN
models uh that's incredibly memory
efficient. it's able to use CPUs and
GPUs at like full capacity and and so
you can do something like train massive
models in in a day instead of in in a
month. Uh and then and then there's
other ways of thinking about creating
models that are more cognizant of
representation space and I'm going to
mention the node piece model which has
got me quite excited. I'm yeah again
this is from from Michael's work but
it's it's a really important thought.
How do we have graphs that are bigger
that all fit into the memory on our
GPUs? Well, we can hope that GPUs get
bigger memory, but our graphs will grow
faster than GPU memory. And and now we
have to like go into this this
nitty-gritty machine learning
engineering thing. How do we how do we
scale across different GPUs on different
systems? Um, do we need to do
networking? All this stuff that's I mean
it's beyond me. I [laughter] I I'll say
it. uh and I think a lot of people also
are are worried about this because it's
it's an complete engineering and devops
problem that we need to support research
and application of machine learning.
Now, if we can do a really good job
getting that stuff working and I think
that there's a lot of more general tools
like PyTorch, Lightning, um, and other
kinds of, you know, the distributed
stack within PyTorch even, uh, are are
enabling this, but you know, it's it's
not so easy. And also, we have this
global shortage of GPUs right now
because of those awful cryptocurrency
people. Um, different problem. Yeah.
Yeah. But, uh, this this will kind of
push us forwards. And one one thing that
worries me is that when we sort of hit
the limit where it's kind of harder to
make these improvements that the the
hype will shift and GNN's will end and
people will move on to the next thing. I
don't know what the next thing is going
to be but uh you know we we've seen it
in the last six or seven years. I when I
started you know in in chemoirmatics
SVMs were still hot and you know since
then a lot of cool stuff has happened
and people have have shuttled through
you know variational autoenccoders and
now to GNN's and so like it doesn't mean
that people aren't doing variational
autoenccoders anymore but the field is
[clears throat] more or less moved on
from how research is is being shown so
so okay this could happen in any field
and I'm worried that you know the future
of the method is rather than improving
is people giving up on it and uh you
know all us on the panel, we're all
quite young actually uh in scope of
things. So, so we haven't seen so many
hype cycles go by, but I think uh other
people will say, "Yeah, you know, I
mentioned kernel methods back in the
beginning. Every time I present
something on this, some of the guys who
have been around and they were doing
research in the end of the 80s, they're
like, "Yeah, we did this already." Oh,
uh oh, what do I say to that?
So, anyway, let's let's hope that
everyone writes really good software and
that it can be trained really fast so we
can do lots of cool things. The thing
I'd like to see is let's say all these
problems are solved and we can scale up
and we can train fast and we have good
models that we can rely on is I want to
see you know the same kind of rigor
applied to machine learning uh in in the
the knowledge graph world that it's been
applied in other things like give me you
know five replicates of your experiment
please and uh you know do do some
permutation testing to check if if the
structure of your graph like actually
means something I I've never seen a
paper published on this uh in in the
collaboration with with Astroenica sort
of convinced them, hey, why don't you
try this? And then they, you know, they
blew three months of GPU time to run
five replicates of each of their
experiments. And then they presented,
you know, a bar chart instead of just a
a table that said, here's our mean rank.
And I was so excited. But, uh, you know,
okay, this is the first paper I've ever
seen that did this. It's going to take a
whole movement of people presenting
things like this. Um, and yeah, then
maybe we should be presenting like our
mean scores over five different random
seeds instead of like maybe just the
maximum score and saying, "Hey, we're
wonderful. We beat the state-of-the-art
when maybe your worst score was below
state-of-the-art by a lot."
Are you sensing a theme in like all the
things I've been talking about?
[laughter]
>> Very relevant. I see that a lot and
unfortunately a lot in uh and current
research and so many papers appearing on
archive without without code available
without with the weirdly defined rep
setups experimental setups which are
hardly reproducible.
Uh yeah it is it's painful to see that.
Uh Tiffany would would you like to
comment also on that uh question of uh
locking out with large with large
models? Yes, absolutely. And again, I'll
say I'm coming from the the clinical
perspective because many of the reasons
that I use knowledge graphs is to
hopefully improve things we can do at
the bedside. And so I think the uh in
agreement with Andrea, I'm about small
models now just because the imple
implications of patients are are really
real. And so I' I'd opt on the side
first of being more confident and
careful. But I think I see a a world of
both hopefully where you can leverage
smaller models in the downstream finer
tuning stage of your learning process,
but also take advantage of of bigger
models where you can get away with
things being less
confident, accurate, if you will. Not to
say that big models don't do accurate
things. And I think there's absolutely a
danger in the health care setting of
things becoming proprietary very
quickly, especially when you have giants
like Epic who want to move into beyond
just controlling electronic health
records and improving analytics that sit
on top of them. I think there's a real
danger, not to say anything negative
about Epic, but they tend to make things
much less open and available to do
research on. Hopefully that partnership
could grow into something. Uh, but I'm
not not 100% sure about that. And I
think just to follow up on one thing
that Charlie said, I I think the
strategy from the biomedical field in
general should be wherever we can for
those people who are really good at this
on improving the existing set of models
to make them faster and and able to
process existing things first and then
we can build on that. So there's a group
from the University of Milan, Giorgio
Valentini's group is using Rust to
improve even simple node tovec type
models which is exciting because you can
do a lot with that and grow on top of
that. But just to see that you can take
something like wiki data and run it in
memory with the way that they've
optimized their configuration of that
model is really exciting.
So hopefully we see more growth from
people who are good at optimizing models
but also the the focus on what matters
in terms of again I keep pushing back on
consulting with the right domain experts
to make sure that the tool that you have
available can actually solve the problem
that you're working with them to solve.
>> And then a question to Sergey on that.
Oh yes sorry.
I'm actually just curious if what the
the people listening to us are thinking.
Can we make a quick poll? Do they think
like a small models or large models with
large data?
>> I don't know. I would do it myself but I
don't know from where
>> it's a great idea. I'm curious too.
>> H sorry would you like to for me to
initiate a poll?
>> Yes.
>> What's the subject exactly?
>> Small model smaller models or big
models?
>> Doesn't matter. question question mark.
[laughter]
>> Give me a few seconds. You can go on. Of
course.
>> Wonderful suggestion.
>> Yeah. I had a question to Sergey about
uh costs of uh applying bigger models or
smaller models in industrial tasks
because it might seem uh that uh uh if
you apply a big model in some I don't
know some GP3 which has organized uh
inference and bill billing procedure
would would it be cheaper or more
expensive to spin up something large but
with well- definfined access or you
would link or some uh open.
>> You can find the poll. Sorry for the
interruption, Michael. You can find the
poll on the footer.
>> Yes, we see.
>> Let's go.
>> Let's keep going while the voting's
happening.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. So uh the question is uh like what
what is the cost basically of applying
big models in in the industry right so
models like
>> maybe it's cheaper maybe the cost of
tinkering smaller model will be higher
because you need to adopt the open
source h code to to your
>> okay so
um I I I think there are like two two
type of costs one one type of quotes is
uh just building the model itself. Like
how how do how easy it is to for you as
a research or engineer to build a model
meaning that you need to build a data
set for it, you need to schedule it, you
need to train it, uh you need to make
sure that inference works correctly and
fast enough. uh and the same uh the
second type of of the cost is really how
much money do you need to spend in order
to train it regularly and also
um in order to store all the results
from from this model uh for example it
could be representations of this model.
So I think speaking of the first uh cost
uh it it is it is important and of
course uh each model uh go undergoes
several tests uh in order to to decide
whether we we can apply this model uh in
production. So what one of the biggest
uh challenges is how to make inference
uh fast. So again I'm I'm speaking about
specific uh specific problems in in
graph machine learning when you need to
recommend something. So it's it's not
the case I guess for um for drug
discovery for example where where you
can do everything offline and of course
you care about how how fast you train
but I think you are not cons as much
constrained in in terms of the inference
speed uh that you have to do. So as if
you have these constraints on on the
inference of course you you need to make
sure that uh the model is not complex
enough and uh different companies have
different uh constraints but uh I I
could say that um uh using something
like transformer for inference is is not
possible. So no one no one uses uh
transformer uh online uh for
recommendation. So like for YouTube for
example um and then there is a question
of how easy to develop the model, how
easy to generate the data set and uh
that all depends on on the on the
particular task again uh but for for
graphs obviously you have this
additional uh task that you need to take
care of uh which is how to build the
graph how to make sure that uh the node
features are correct and not missing and
what do you do with different scales of
the node features and so on. So this is
a this is a costly procedure and uh um
if you if you resolve it you're good. Uh
if not then yeah you you need maybe to
work uh months with engineers just to
get the uh the the correct graphs and
and then speaking of the real dollars
that that people um uh put into training
the models and into uh running the
models in production. So uh when you
decide on on the
uh cost in terms of dollars uh usually
have the training phase. So the training
phase is usually determined by the
available uh compute resources that you
have. Uh so in many companies you
already have predefined uh uh clusters.
So you don't run it in Amazon. you you
have your own cluster in which case you
can occupy it as much as you want as
long as uh other people allow you to. Um
so that's kind of we we can don't think
about this part of the of the cost and
the second is uh the real storage that
uh you incur when you train the model.
So for example, you train the embeddings
for um for products users and then you
you have to real uh re really count how
much memory does it take and then uh um
and then um determine and calculate uh
how much dollars it will cost you and
and make a decision. So the decision is
based on how much value it brings, how
much dollars does it bring to you or how
like based on some other business
metrics compared to the cost that it
takes to to train your model and also
run your model. Uh and of course if if
your model um uh uh net negative then
you don't uh deploy this model so you
throw away and uh continue. If it's
positive then you have to take other uh
concern into account such as uh how easy
it would be to maintain this model
because you don't just want to deploy it
you also want to uh make sure that it
will not break in the future if
something changes and who will support
it in the future and so on. So if it's
net positive then if it's really not
positive then you you run it. If it's uh
somewhere neutral you may abandon this
this model. So this is kind of the type
of reasoning we have when we decide uh
what is the cost of of running the model
and um answering your uh question
whether it's easier to to run it like
GPT3 model instead of some easier model
I think uh uh like for online task you
of course cannot run something like GIT3
but uh for offline tasks uh you just
calculate how much money will it cost to
you to to train and and and run it and
then you compare it to the business
value that it brings to you and and and
make this business decision.
I hope that clarifies.
Yes. And as we have a few minutes uh uh
I'd like to ask our speakers a question
about the
the holy grail. What is the next holy
grail of graphanel research? And it's
serious is
you you were talking about industrial
applications uh and point at an industry
what would be your like this holy grail
task something that has not yet been
solved but you would want uh to have it
solved which would have some profound
impact on your everyday life.
>> Yeah this is a great question that I
asked myself many times uh and I'm I'm
looking forward to hear your answers as
well. Um I I wrote this blog post in the
beginning of this year on the applica
top applications of GNN's that I uh kind
of uh uh saw and uh speaking with
different uh practitioners in this
field. I think that the most u
um optimistic and promising application
would be drug discovery and in general
uh material design or anything that
works with uh uh with molecules or or
materials. So it's it's it's not just
drug discovery even though I think it's
uh as I said the most promising I think
there more startups right now uh bigger
companies look into this area and try to
apply graph models uh it could be also
um designing materials for uh for better
storage. So uh competitions like open
catalyst uh by by Facebook and uh CMU I
think um uh is a great example of this
and uh more companies that that I speak
to not not just uh not just uh
biological companies like Astroenica uh
but also big IT companies um for example
in Russia we have bank which is the huge
bank uh it has a huge uh compute
resources and it decides to um you know
work on AI and uh one of the branches is
working on AI for biology and material
design. So this is uh an example of big
IT companies going to pharma going into
uh kind of energy and and other uh
natural sciences. Um so this is one um
the second that I'm uh this is more like
research topic and I'm I'm coming from
math background. So um I'm I'm I'm
really interested in solving some
long-standing math problems. So you know
the graph is morphine problems is one of
the holy grace in graph theory. So I was
always dreaming that was my kind of
childhood dream to to prove a graph of
the morphine problem. Then I realized
I'm stupid enough not to uh not to prove
it. So I decided to not not to pursue
this. But um guess what uh right now
there is a line of research that trying
to uh use AI to um
work on math problems. So in particular
I'm uh working with some uh some other
researchers on on a problem of
disproving uh conjectures in in graph
theory. So you know that uh for example
there is a reconstruction conjectures
the one of the most famous uh in graph
theory. Um so it's it's a similar to
drug discovery setup. You need to
generate the graphs that will disprove
some conjecture. Um and it's kind of
cooler than drug discovery because you
don't need to run lab experiments to to
prove that your molecule is great
because you immediately get the result
uh by disproving the conject conjecture
and it's easy. Uh so I think this is a
very very cool uh maybe not as useful as
as as uh developing new drugs but still
a very very cool uh area of research and
uh I hope that uh there will be more and
more um um approaches uh for helping not
just natural sciences but also something
fundamental fundamental as as
mathematics. But yeah, I'm looking
forward to to hear you guys.
I think my thoughts align quite well
with Sergey. So I just uh continue in
that uh so I I have a shameless plug on
the graph theory. I I recorded myself
giving a presentation which I think will
be played on Friday. Um I I do have a
bit of a different view on how uh on the
graph theory in graph machine learning
uh in the sense of I think we should
have our so there are algorithms that
are of interest um and we know like the
those are the algorithms we run for
example shortest path for some
transportation problem. Um so I think if
we are going to apply graph machine
learning to transportation navigation
and that sort of task it would be useful
to have uh models learn about these
algorithms we know would be useful. or
have a model trains to imitate I don't
know belong for or something like that
and that's what I'm talking in the talk
and I think that sort of aligns with
what in in in a from a different
perspective with what Sergey was saying
like I think there should be some uh
connection between graph theory and
models like neuronet for example uh and
I also think drug discovery is one of
the very promising fields uh there's a
lot of resources being put I think ma
has a big push in the direction. Uh my
own group works a lot on on that. So
yeah, the drug discovery seems very
promising. Uh but of course like it's
not just drugs, materials too. As Sergey
was saying, I think chip chip design
could is also interesting. Uh yeah, I
think that there's a lot of of potential
in in some very defined tasks where we
know precisely what we're solving and
those would be like the the first uh
domains I think graph machine learning
will show more promise than they've
shown shown already.
>> Well, is it okay if I go next, Charlie?
I don't want to leave you last.
>> I think we might overlap in this too. I
think again coming from the the
biomedical domain and building on the
prior two speakers I think I'd like to
see models that are able to do more
mechanistic causal inference and provide
enough evidence as to self-explain why
they came up with that solution. So I
think the things that were mentioned
prior, things like drug discovery,
things like coming up with u new kinds
of recommendations for treatments of
similar diseases could benefit from from
really well-formed mechanistic inference
and and building on traditional probable
probability and causal models like what
Judah Pearl has proposed, but on a much
larger scale. And that's that's where
I'm hoping things will go and I think
Charlie will will probably build on
that.
you're still welcome to join our Judea
Procausal inference Wednesday reading
group. Yeah.
>> Um yeah,
>> I'll go in a different direction since
we we talked so much about biology
today. I think one of the deep pro
besides all the engineering stuff that I
keep talking about this all really
important. Um one thing that I want to
see which I don't think is super popular
right now is sort of better theoretical
basis for the models we're building. I
think it's quite cool the way people
formalized as as I very slowly learned
about how knowledge graph embedding
models were formalized um all the way
back from these original like bordis
papers with like the the simple models
with the dismal and rescal and then all
the way until the absolutely elegant
formalizations of GNN's which until they
got to message passing it and just kind
of blew my mind. Um what we don't have
is like real statistical interpretations
of these models. When I make a
prediction, I get some some numbers out
from some interaction function after
passing through and and it's based on
some loss that you define and there's a
couple different levels to it, but in
the end I get some numbers and depending
on the way that the models and the
software is formulated. It could be like
some values between negative infinity
and infinity maybe where the more
negative it is the more likely it is to
be a real relationship and maybe the
more positive is also depends on who you
are and if you like negative signs but I
want to see I want to see a probability.
I want to see one means this really
should be an edge and zero means
probably not. uh and to go from some
some numbers between negative infinity
and infinity. Uh you can you can apply
certain kinds of like soft max or or
related transforms. Sure. But that
doesn't turn things into probability uh
with with some sort of theoretical
underpinning of why one is good and zero
is bad or or you know maybe the opposite
if you think like a p value maybe closer
to zero is better. Um, we don't have
that yet and it's not a super popular
area of research, but I think it might
give us more insight into the the things
that come out of our models and how much
we can really trust them.
Yeah, that is a we have collected a good
bunch of uh of those promising areas. Uh
yeah, let me reconcilate those uh
mentioned. So it is drug discovery, it
is material design. Uh it is uh a bit
more on the theoretical side. It's the
uh graphisomorphisms, unsolved
isomorphism problem, theoretical
problems and a general understanding the
the theoretical foundation of uh
relational modeling of relational
learning uh with statistical and causal
interpretations that would allow us to
actually get the yeah get them
mechanistic interpretation of what what
is happening there which is uh something
that we we lack indeed.
Uh yeah and causal inference expl having
having explainable models. Uh that is
very important that there were only
unfortunately only few works recently on
explaining uh how those uh app models
work. Uh yeah and let's uh see what the
our poll results are. So the majority
the bigger majority uh 73%
votes for smaller models.
Uh yeah, it it seems that
the community still wants to have to
retain some sort of sovereignty or
independence
when they when they work with models and
not to leave the inference and all this
implementation stuff to to to bigger
companies. That's let's see how it how
it works in uh in in few years when I'm
sure there will be even bigger
foundation models that can sort that can
solve more tasks or we will be able to
uh create very targeted and target
models that can largely outperform the
those huge uh pay wall models. Uh yeah
with that uh we are uh we are
approaching the end of our session. I
would like to thank our speakers very
very much for joining from different all
over the world from different places. Uh
I would like to remind our audience that
Andrea's talk is on Friday to visit
Andrea talk uh uh at the at the
conference on Friday and uh with that
yeah uh thank you very much everyone and
uh have have a nice day. Thanks. Thanks
connected data world organizers host for
letting us conduct conduct this
wonderful conversation.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
>> Yeah. And uh see you at the conference.
Thank you everybody guys. Bye.